just like I've added I've subtractive
multiplication is just another operation
no big deal right so I can multiply P by
Q I'm not going to put an altercation
song in there because I got X is flying
around that looks a bit confusing P
times Q that's just the first player
multiplied by the second one
it's not rocket science I just never
seen it with this notation before so I
say in course lime on x lines too so
that's 4x takeaway 3x squared plus 7x
posture okay now there's a variety of
ways that you can do this but just
before we actually start doing it you've
got two terms here and you've got three
terms here
right I've talked about this before that
when you're expanding our terms like
this it's kind of like each of these
terms at the front it's going to say hi
to everyone of these people inside the
house right so for example this 4x is
gonna say hi to this guy and is gonna be
and this guy right and then the negative
three repeats the process for this guy
and this guy and this guy now how many
error is it by drawing I've drawn six
hours because I have to do three and
then I do another three two times three
right so I know right from the get-go
before I even start I should get six
terms at the end and then some of them
are gonna collect together okay if I
have three terms in this polynomial and
three here how many terms would I expect
at the end nine right in five four and
three I get well well however many here
okay now the reason why I'm doing this
mentally is because the error I see
happening again and again is students
miss terms they're like here times here
and they end up with like four terms or
five and they don't realize they're
missing one it's not hard to notice how
many we should have so let's actually do
it we'll do the green ones first because
they're first so I'm going to do 4x
times each one of these in turn help me
up 4x times x squared 4x cubed 4x times
7x 28 x squared 4x times 2x
sorry it's just times two that's just a
10
and they're all positive which is really
nice I've done all the green months now
do little red ones and then see you let
me see any on right so I'm going to
minus 3x squared minus telling us the
next one 21 X minus 6 done okay
I've expended all that and now I just
need to collect like terms and I have a
whole bunch and I'm going to use my
colors again to help me how many X cubed
terms do you see just the one so he's
just gonna hang out the phone
how many x squared times you sit - right
there's one there's the other one how
many X times on it again there are two
and then you just got that constant term
hanging at the end okay does that make
sense so let's have a look here for X
cubed how many X Squared's will I have
in total 28 take away 3 which is 25 it's
okay you want this about it 8 take away
21 is negative 36 and minus 13x
and then we already mentioned that that
constants hanging out there now really
really quickly I just want to point out
to you what was the degree of that first
polynomial what's the degree of pain
the degree of pain was just 1 remember
added in 0x squared
but there aren't really any x squared
terms there right so it's actually just
that so the degree is 1 okay let me just
write that degree 1 what was the degree
of the second polynomial dude that was
fine
okay when you added the polynomials
together what was the degree that you
got this this one here are now the
highest powers still - I had built it
from here my turn degree - when I
subtracted what degree did I get still -
but when I multiplied because you're
gonna get this leading code liter and
this leading term they got to multiply
together the degree changes do you
notice that my degree now is 3
okay now just predict just predict
suppose I actually did have an x squared
term at the front okay
suppose I had you know five x squared
here there would be degree 2 degree two
what would happen when we multiplied the
whole thing out the the leading terms
are always going to multiply exactly
once right and so you're going to have
an x squared term times another x
squared term so degree 2 and degree 2
would become degree 4 right what about
if you had something ridiculous like
degree 11 you had some X to the power of
11 and degree I don't know you some
other write a number like 7 okay when
you multiply them again there's in the
in terms which have X to the 11 and X to
the 7th however many of them there are
there will be by our in explores XP 18
so your degree of the product ends up
being the sum of the degrees of what you
multiplying your factors okay so this is
a pattern I wanted you to notice gonna
become critically important when we have
a look at the next thing after adding
subtracting multiplying which you would
guess is dividing dividing is hard but
look at that I have defined a whole
listen to it